so you're the Chinese Communist party or
CCP your mission is clear if you're
plebs are obedient and productive your
economy makes more money and therefore
you get more money and power however if
they're disobedient and not a productive
member of society you are screwed all
your money and power will vanish away so
you gotta do everything in your power to
keep the sheep in line but the problem
is living in China kind of sucks for a
variety of reasons so between 2000 and
2021 over 6.9 million people have fled
China 6.9 million of your servants gone
out of your reach not making your
economy money they betrayed the
motherland to enjoy life elsewhere and
for a ruthless authoritarian like
yourself that is unacceptable because
people fleeing will make other people
want to flee and if people were to flee
in masses your economy would collapse
taking your money in power with it
so here's what you gotta do number one
you gotta make it super hard for people
to leave China in the first place which
we've covered in other videos and number
two You Gotta Sink your teeth into
Chinese citizens living abroad you gotta
be able to keep tabs on them intimidate
them blackmail them all in an effort to
round them up and bring them back home
that way they can get back to work
making you money and not making money
for America or Europe or whatever what
you need is a secret police force
stationed all over the world Chinese
government has set up secret police
stations in 54 countries around the
world secret police units so ruthless
that no one would dare disobey them and
guess what China's secret police have
already infiltrated America along with
the rest of the world the CCP is making
their message clearer no matter where
you run no matter where you hide the
Chinese government will always be right
around the corner you will never be safe
anywhere in the world
anywhere
China's International secret police is
very sketchy and bad but nothing
compares to the evil some Chinese
citizens have to face back home forced
organ harvesting with a Chinese military
and hospitals forcibly harvest the
organs of prisoners why because money of
course rich people in need of an organ
transplant will pay a lot of money in
order to save their own life they're not
gonna look into where or how this organ
came about China saw this massive
opportunity and they pounced
unfortunately this subject is way too
gruesome to be monetized on YouTube so
we've just released it as a private
documentary that you can watch right now
by pausing the video scrolling down and
clicking that join button below this
YouTube membership is where we post
documentaries every single month that
we've always wanted to make but can't
and members love them and there's a
30-day refund policy too if this is your
first time joining so you have nothing
to lose and people really ask for a
refund anyways because it's just that
good so pause the video scroll down and
click that join button now now back to
China's secret police
if you're gonna be sending Chinese
police forces to operate in foreign
countries you're going to need a good
excuse because this is definitely very
illegal your excuse is simple online
fraud think about it since China's rise
there have been many great opportunities
for entrepreneurs to build new
successful businesses including online
scams I'm sure all of us have gotten the
occasional sketchy message containing
Chinese words about how your account has
been hacked or that you won some money
over the years online fraud has become a
huge problem in China so the CCP began a
vicious Crackdown on it where you're
basically hunting these internet
scammers down like they were terrorists
but what do ambitious scammers do when
they get chased by the CCP they move
abroad to nearby countries like Myanmar
Laos Thailand or Cambodia all these
scammers had to do was move to one of
these countries and they were free and
clear so the CCP simply decided that all
these countries like Myanmar and Laos
are now quote forbidden countries end
quote where Chinese citizens are no
longer allowed to travel or live in
unless they have a really good reason
for it which most people don't but that
was still not enough declaring those
countries a forbidden zone for Chinese
citizens stopped people from moving
there but it didn't bring home the
Chinese citizens already living there so
in the last few years the CCP has tried
everything in its power to persuade
Chinese citizens in those countries to
return home they've done everything from
blackmailing them to threatening their
relatives and it didn't matter whether
you were a scammer a big time criminal
or totally innocent the CCP didn't care
about stupid things like evidence or
proof to you anyone who dares to leave
China is either a scammer or worse so
every single Chinese citizen living in
those forbidden countries was pretty
much automatically designated a criminal
even if you're a 60 year old lady who
just wants to enjoy your retirement in
an exotic country like Thailand nope now
you're a criminal worthy of being hunted
down by the full force of China's police
the problem was that blackmailing them
threatening their relatives and freezing
their bank accounts back home would only
go so far their reach and influence was
limited they could easily find
workarounds to your threats like opening
up a foreign bank account you need
something more you need boots on the
ground if you had police stations in
every major European American and Asian
City you could be way more persuasive in
your attempts to keep your citizens
under control and maybe even get them
back home it would be so much more
effective than just threatening people
over the phone or through their
relatives and plus your excuse of
combating online scammers was great
optically you're fighting for justice
after all these people scam the elderly
for crying out loud who can argue
against such a noble cause on top of
that you've laid the groundwork for this
in 2014 you made France sign an
agreement to have Chinese police patrol
tourist areas in Paris a year later you
did the same thing in Italy suddenly
Chinese police forces were strolling
around round in Rome all for the safety
and protection of Chinese citizens of
course then in 2019 Serbia signed an
agreement to let Chinese police forces
roam through Belgrade little by little
your CCP police units infiltrated dozens
of cities around the world
but that was only the beginning of your
master plan now that you had the perfect
reason for your Global police force to
be roaming around Europe it's time to go
one step further it's time for you to
flood the entire world with your secret
points starting with the United States
foreign
[Music]
one one zero overseas the official
overseas CCP police force to the world
110 overseas has only one purpose to
stop online scammers the idea is that if
you're from China and you're scammed by
some other Chinese person abroad you can
report it to these authorities simply
call the local number tell them what
happened and they'll bring the scammers
to Justice how they would bring them to
justice and if that is at all legal
don't worry about it but that's not all
Chinese citizens can also call them to
renew their documents or report any
other problems they may be having that's
why they're calling these secret police
stations Police Service Centers this
isn't some scary secret police force
you're just trying to help ordinary
Chinese citizens in times of need but
behind closed doors you know the truth
these Police Service Centers aren't
there to help Chinese migrants they're
just a mere facade for a much more
Sinister Mission the app absolute
control over Chinese people no matter
where they're located in the world
the Chinese government has already set
up over 50 of these police service
centers around the world including New
York City yes the ccp's very owned
secret police roaming the streets of
Manhattan their headquarters an office
above a noodle shop somewhere on the
Lower East Side and they've been busy in
2020 the ccp's attempts to force Chinese
people to come back to China have become
so severe that the FBI had to intervene
and New York isn't the only city where
ccp's secret police are roaming the
streets they've set up police stations
in Paris Toronto London Madrid Barcelona
Sydney and Tokyo they are practically
everywhere operating in more than 21
countries across five continents
unfortunately you're not gonna walk past
a giant sign in New York City that says
Chinese Police Service Center oh no no
no they're setting up shop hidden inside
chinese-owned establishments to keep a
low profile in Dublin Ireland they're
operating from a Chinese supermarket in
Glasgow Scotland they're working from a
Chinese restaurant it's like how the
mafia have front businesses they use to
launder money except instead of
laundering money it's to kidnap and
intimidate people so let's say you're
one of these Noble secret police
officers operating out of a Chinese
supermarket what kind of tactics are you
going to be using to service your
Chinese brethren
thank you
once you have a Chinese citizen in your
crosshairs it's all about finding
leverage threaten to freeze their bank
account or the bank accounts of their
family members tell them their kids or
grandkids will be forced to drop out of
school in China if you don't comply that
their parents may lose their social
benefits their home or their business
nothing is off the table do not rest
until you find a way to really hurt them
when that doesn't work that's when you
have to resort to in-person tactics one
woman living in Cambodia was pressured
by Chinese authorities to return to
China just because Cambodia is one of
the nine forbidden countries when she
refused the CCP threatened to cut off
the power and water supply of her
mother's home in China later her
mother's house was spray painted with
the words House of Telecom fraud in
Myanmar The CCP threatened Chinese
citizens to come back home or quote the
bank accounts of their immediate family
members and friends would be controlled
restricted or canceled end quote between
April 2021 and July 2022 over 230 000
Chinese citizens were forced to return
from overseas whether they were actual
criminals didn't matter it's about
stopping Chinese citizens from even
thinking about leaving the motherland in
the first place you have to take away
all of their hope for a better life
abroad
China's secret police may be causing
chaos all around the world but honestly
their International Mo for dealing with
misbehaving citizens is a lot more PG
rated than what they do to their people
back home in China they actually get
punished and not only is the punishment
more severe than anything we've talked
about on this channel before it's also
way more profitable we are talking about
forced organ harvesting China's go-to
punishment for activists and dissidents
you see China realized something there's
a lot of demand for fresh healthy organs
on the international market there are a
lot of sick wealthy people who
desperately need organ transplants to
survive unfortunately the global supply
of organs is pretty low
on average you have to wait three to
five years for an organ transplant
because there's really only so many
people willing to give up their organs
of their own free will
so China got to thinking it had some of
the biggest prisoner populations in the
world with loads of Juicy organs
available
why not solve the global organ deficit
and become stinking rich in the process
by harvesting organs by force how much
money would a Millionaire on his
deathbed pay for a second chance at life
for an expedited organ that he could
order whenever he needed and so
hospitals in China found their new money
maker forced organ harvesting they've
gotten the system down so well that they
are actually advertising organ
transplant waiting times of a few weeks
come compared to the rest of the world's
pathetic three-year minimum wait time
all they had to do was conveniently
leave out the part where the people they
were getting their organs from weren't
exactly willing volunteers
are definitely not dying on their own
time but as you probably expect talking
about such a graphic Topic in a public
YouTube video would equal instant
demonetization that's why we've just
released a private documentary exposing
China's forced organ harvesting and it's
only available to members of this
Channel all you have to do to watch it
right now is scroll down and hit that
join button below once you join you'll
get unlimited access to this documentary
as well as all of our other previous
videos that channel members have been
loving this YouTube membership has
allowed us to release videos on topics
we've always wanted to cover but would
never fly on YouTube and it's super
affordable too compared to something
like college where they don't teach you
how the world works at all it's just
five dollars a month and there's a
refund policy too unlike most YouTube
memberships so if you join and you don't
think it's worth it email us within your
first month of joining for the first
time and we will personally refund you
for your first month after your first
month there is no refund so scroll down
and click that join button below now
[Music]